Trisha Paytas legend icon dancer singer
actress personality fast talker TV mogul
YouTube Queen meme legend Wow so many
titles so little time author oh yeah box
create even begin begin with you chest
first of all I mean how are you doing
let's start there how are you very well
I feel like the whole internet thinks
I'm about off the ledge but I'm like I'm
out of blood I'm like this way you
always bounce back from just about
anything it's been over it what over 10
years of youtube we've seen you go
through with so many apps so many downs
that we always see you come back yeah
that's me thank God because truly you
just you deliver what no other girls can
to say the least
I feel like I'm like the old person of
YouTube like I'm here still here still
kicking still getting views you know I
track so obviously you've been dealing
with a lot of drama recently no stranger
to a scandal so let's just quick a
little recap you went through a lot all
that once I feel like you know you went
through the h3h3 video you went through
the nikah kata avocado feud he got over
the Jason breakup pewdiepie came from oh
my god the pewdiepie video it hasn't
ended this past month how have you been
able to cope and deal with everything
that's been thrown your way recently you
know why honestly I have just been able
like just YouTube like doing videos
which every was like you take a break
but like I used to like do a bunch of
pills and drugs but like I don't do that
anymore so now I just do like YouTube
and like that's the only thing that gets
me through and Jesus of course of course
yeah we love it and because yeah you
mean you did say we're gonna take a
break for a minute and I think the next
day you're back taking a break like I'm
not and if I ever do take a break then
you need to worry oh no that's what the
second you said that medication well
we'll see you tomorrow
okay like five hours later I'm like by
the way I missed you guys that's all I
have like literally all I have I sit in
my house most days when I'm like not
doing something and like which is
usually every day and I just like sit
there and I'm like what can I do who can
I talk to and then I'll put like a satin
stir
no one responds hummock all right let's
do a YouTube video out of everything
that you've had to deal with recently
what what's been like the most difficult
thing to overcome prank that yeah
obviously that one is that this is a
hard one this is like someone who like
actually like claimed to me as a
girlfriend I feel like all my other
boyfriend's like did it and so like this
one was hard because like I feel like
genuinely like day in day out with it we
were together 24 hours a day for like
306 five days like never apart so it's
hard that's like a drug looking back
would you have done anything differently
as far as the way that you shared to be
relationship where do you think you know
this is your your job and you had to do
what you had to do basically yeah I
loved it I actually loved everything
like I that was probably best during my
life with David and Jason I kind of was
like we were in a trio obviously I
probably like shouldn't have made a
video about people that weren't involved
in the situation but you know it happens
I have a big mouth and like I was
emotional sometimes a girl just has to
snap and that that's that on that you'd
snap so I don't know we'll try the next
relationship have you heard from Jason
or anyone from the vlog squad since has
anyone reached out yes yes people have
reached out a couple like like
depression say their names but like
people I would never expect from the
group have like reached out even as as
recent as like a week ago one of the
girls reached out to me I was shocked
and she was so sweet and so compassion I
was like oh my god and one of the guys
did too um but yeah having heard from
Jason since my birthday we were cool and
the David I haven't heard from he
literally was just like bye are you
keeping I've been like you're keeping up
with their videos or anything moving on
no I love stalking all ex-boyfriends I
stopped the one from a teen stuff he's
getting married his new girlfriend's in
the new couldn't turn teen a movie house
like alright good for him I will say I
did click on a Jason video and I thought
I was going to talk about you and then I
stopped it was like 35 minutes and I'm
on that I type in all the time like
Titian Saoirse and they're like he
talked about me at a stand up shout I
was so excited dad were so over there's
no going back from what I did but like
at the same time it's so fun to keep I
could be like they mention me I'm so
narcissistic I would be very much the
same as you know so I honest I can't
follow you I can't fault you yeah
loves it too he's kind of a narcissist
so I'm sure he loves the other are you
done though with people like tweeting
you all the time like when like when the
timber profile happened it works me in
that to you as that stuff kind of just
like okay over like in that regards
moving on or no oh my god someone tagged
me the other day like he liked this
girl's ass photo I was like okay like
and it doesn't bother you for a minute
but here I am - I'm all like trying to
like hook up with every person I see so
it's just like I can't really hold it
yeah that's annoying but I think it's
like the same hater that tries to like
get me to like snap but I've already
snapped there's no going further awful
edge I've already jumped and burned all
the bridges that flames - all of them
there's no like I can't do anymore so do
you think that maybe months years from
now you guys could have a friendship
again or do you think it's pretty much
just done at this point me and Jason
yeah I don't know I was pretty crazy
I was pretty crazy I I probably would
say like when something's done I like
have to explode I have to like make it
like just literally non-repairable but
who knows Jason's also Jason's crazier
than me obviously you guys just don't
see it he's a nutjob so maybe you guys
just have like you two together was just
always such a sight so you know I will
sit be sitting I wish and just at least
for a friendship because y'all are fun
yeah we're functioning not jobs we're
not harmful or dangerous money to live
for with the feud with Nick ricotta
avocado there was a second there where
you were losing a lot of subscribers was
there a moment though when you were
shocked or even maybe a little bit
scared about just seeing people
unsubscribe or hate on yes I'm still
losing I think when I was like 3,000 a
day Wow yeah no you know I don't I don't
get worried about it like I just like if
people leave they leave I just not to
like quote Logan Paul but he said
something really kind of like it hit me
like so crazy I know his podcast where
he said like he's not here to like
convert people to like him even my
therapist says that - they're like you
can't convince people that you're not a
liar like if they want to believe you're
a liar they're gonna believe it you
can't convince people so like that's
kind of where I'm at I'm like I can't
convince people to like me I want them
to like me but I can't and also like you
know views are up monthly I got thirty
five million views a month
subscribers what people are clicking
what's the one biggest takeaway that you
would want people to know about
everything that you went through
recently that it's like that you know
one thing that I wish I just hope people
like no because all I have is like my
truth right like all my youtube channel
is my life and who I am like so if
people don't think I'm authentic that
like that hurts the most like everything
I went through it's like I can be here
now be like got the views the views are
up work great but like it was traumatic
like everything was traumatic it started
out my birthday which was May 8th you
know Jason cutting me off for good like
that was so it was like going through
the breakup all over again some ago this
is like real real then may 8th was the
h3 video he posted the video on my
birthday and I didn't see it till May
9th the Nick Cano videos May 10th
PewDiePie was me you know so like all
that just spiraled spiraled spiraled
meanwhile also dealing with like crazy a
crazy big pill addiction I have and also
I tried really hardcore drugs and I was
like 3 months of our break so like
coming back from a mental hospital you
don't I mean like it was so I guess the
main takeaway is like all that stuff is
like real like I'm a real person like
everything was like hitting me hard
there was never like a video where I was
talking about my emotions that was a
control a lot of people thought the h3
videos and control it wasn't like I was
really upset that morning cuz you know
that was the night we got a big fight
and then I saw I really was upset do I
am i over like react reactive yeah but
like that was all real and it's like it
all hurts like the nick econo stuff
hurts like anyone thinking and I would
try and hurt someone a purpose all hurts
it sucks like I don't want to be a bad
person but I'm not a great I'm like I'm
a good person I just make bad decisions
sometimes sometimes yeah you know I mean
at some times I don't respond to people
you know but that was also 2 years ago
I'm trying to grow yeah a lot of people
now are like very aware of their brands
and how are scared of that but you are
just always yourself another one thank
you yeah no I know people are like
anytime they think I make up anything or
like me like you know
lie about my meltdowns like that's the
stupidest career suicide ever because
like as someone who also works with like
companies like companies get scared of
that stuff companies are like ooh this
is like a liability we don't wanna be
associated with except for Adam and Eve
shout-out but like other than them like
other companies have like being scared
like they lived
are like scared sometimes so it's like
that would literally be so stupid and
I'm all about business and money but
like at the end of the day my emotions
always take precedent so I'm gonna add
rather be real and lose a couple
sponsorships then you know lie about how
I'm feeling well despite everything you
are still booked busy and working very
hard so you have a few projects that I'm
very excited to talk about first of all
let's talk about this upcoming summer
tour because I'm very excited to see
Trish live yeah this is actually called
the heartbreak tour the heartbreak tour
going home yeah you can get tickets it's
the heartbreak tour and yeah I decided I
was going back on fourth and what even
the touring company has been watching my
videos in there just like the people
producing it they're like is she gonna
make it and I was like no no this is
what's gonna save me so like performing
like my therapist asked me what are you
happiest and say I'm when I'm in a
relationship okay he's like well second
and I said what I'm performing and I
love performing love doing music videos
in music like it literally is like me
pretending I'm Britney Spears on stage
so I'm so excited for this tour like
it's it's 14 cities and I'm it's like
double the size of last year the venue
is I'm so excited so what can we expect
to see when you're hitting the stage
lots of dancing cuz like everyone's
always like you dancing your videos like
we never United dance last year so we're
bringing dancers like we're putting on a
full show like I just wanted to be like
the Britney Spears experience but just
like lesser
[Music]
are you gonna be debuting any new music
during the tour - we're working like my
crews we did freaky we're working on a
new album together so I gotta head back
I was like yeah that's my jam so yeah we
have a new album coming out in July and
we're recording it now so yeah and not
only the other tour you are also the
founder of the clever [ __ ] box let's
see what's inside the glitter [ __ ] box
because this is truly something yeah so
we have just a bunch of like branded
products and we have a glitter pop for
our purses so it's just like everything
girly and glittery and sparkly I mean
why did you even come up with this idea
by the way because it's kind of it's
kind of genius
yeah I just you know what we were
thinking about like subscription boxes
and we're like okay we could do like
adult toys I was like no I won't like
glitter cuz you know like I wanted
something for like people love tacky
stuff we all know that you're a very
bougie and you just live that lifestyle
you're that girl how much have you
dropped in one video whoo well music
video probably was thick that was a
hundred and fifty thousand we shop at
Universal Wow yeah we had like rent out
the universal back lot and we had to
like hire their people and hire like a
fire truck and like we had like water
trucks so that was really expensive that
was a two-day shoe and that was a
hundred two thousand so that was crazy
but this next one we're doing is a
Quinton Tarantino inspire we're
recreating that well his movies and
we're shooting at a back lot and that's
about 150,000 so yeah well we got Fabio
that was about a hundred thousand all
right just amble video
my sheets
when you go shopping in a video what's
the craziest amount that you've spent I
recently did wanted to be up with the
trends I was like buying whatever I
touch I didn't really get the idea of
the video cuz I don't watch it on my
idols and I did it and I spent thirty
five thousand Trisha Lin oh my god yeah
that was that was bad oh my god that was
so bad like I really yeah I like needed
to make a tax payment and I was just
like whoa
next month why I then I saw you think
your credit card get declined at a
drive-thru and what I do Trisha
come on honestly that's my life it's
like sometimes it gets to cry really at
home very relatable can you check your
account you owe me another card oh my
god well if you ever wanna do buying
whatever my poor fan touches please let
me know oh you're bougie look at your
shirt yours okay this is bougie on a
budget I got regardless no what do I
love I recently took um one of my
friends she was a subscriber now she's
like my friend I met her on tour last
year name's Amelia I took her to Gucci
and we spent like ten thousand dollars
on her gave her a little makeover Wow
have you been keeping in touch with
Shane and Geoffrey and all your other
friends too because you've logged pretty
much by yourself so it's hard to see
like here so right now it's so true I
know every time I hang out at Shane's
house like it's one of those things he's
so like not that person when I first met
him he was a daily blogger - so we were
always vlogging but there is something
nice about not vlogging all the time but
no I do see a my son for my birthday and
he got me a Cartier bracelet which I'm
not even wearing he got me a Cartier
bracelet which was like so for good
nights he's that he's great he's like
that one person I can call literally
right now and if I'm having like I
really need to see someone he's like
come over and he's always like spend the
night like all that stuff and that whole
group is amazing sighs so I have to
shave all the time he's always been the
nicest and like you know when you think
that whole world is like turning against
you I'm like oh yeah and Geoffrey
contacted me after my breakup videos and
he like he's one of those also people
who sends me like so many voice memos
and just is like so sweet and so nice
like I don't know I like I don't know
where like all the back history of him
comes from but like this Geoffrey I know
is like so nice like both of them don't
need me for literally anything and my
hundred thousand views compared to their
Millions like it does
don't eat so they they will check up on
me and just be like hey hope you're well
which is like so nice so those are like
the two that I will always have like
their back because they've always had
mine like even Shane when I'm like
messing up he's just always like I got
you like and he's the one always brings
me back to reality where he's like he
when the drama happens he's like I
literally have no idea what you're
talking about
and Shane keeps up with YouTube so when
I tell him like everyone hates me
because of this he's a kook what like so
he'll let me know something serious or
not and he's just like no it's like not
that big of a deal
now seeing where everyone is kind of
gone like Shane and Jeffery just have
become like this top God level tier of
you has I've been weird to like process
for you like as their friends yeah other
level I tell me all the time I see him
I'm like oh yeah I forget that he's like
just Shane I was just like wow this is
crazy like he created something so epic
and then Geoffrey too you know but like
she went she Mia when I met him he was
like he was already big but I know I
wasn't as much and so it's just kind of
like it's crazy he's kind of in this
whole other level that's awesome it's
inspiring I was like dang you know I
think it's amazing yeah I have you heard
anything about the series he's working
on with Jeffrey oh my god I literally
can't even say anything cuz but I he he
showed me something last time I saw him
and I started crying I was like oh my
god it's so like I get but I I'm so
excited to see what he does cuz I don't
know like all of it but I'm so excited
because I happen to go over there I
called him one night when I was like so
depressed and like in the middle of my
drama and he was like in the middle of
something so big for his thing
and so I got over there and they were
like all filming stuff like behind the
scenes it asked excited the YouTube in
general has been pretty wild the past
few months when you're watching the
world kind of take sides and James
Charles vs. Jeffrey star and Tati like
what was going through your mind as
someone who's been through a lot of
feuds and those girls watching that
happen yeah you know what I think with
everything like no matter how big your
scandal is it just all goes away so
during it
so she has an outsider and not involved
in that at all it's like oh this is
literally so silly I know with them I'm
sure they were like my world is ending
mm-hmm like that's how I feel through
all my scandals but like I feel like
people forgive scandal even once I
shouldn't be forgiven
honestly I think you can bounce back
from everything so I feel like something
about vitamins and all that stuff I feel
like you know it is silly in the grand
it's owned by a ghost like it's
everything silly in the grand scheme of
things all the girls go through
something at some point basically yeah
for sure I feel like that gives you some
sort of like like yeah it gives us sort
of status right like if you go through
some scandal like you have to like take
a rite of passage
I feel like people are talking about you
I guess it's a good thing I mean I don't
always feel that way oh my god I wish
people wouldn't talk about but if they
are then I guess that's good it's better
than not caring yeah and I feel like now
every time you got to go through
something that's just really hard in
traumatic you owe it like I said he
always bounced back to focus I'm like
your fitness and health so are you still
gonna be like the mukbang queen like
where where is just going I know I don't
even know I'm because part of me is like
oh no more mukbang somewhere my things
but you know then sometimes when I'm
like okay I'm cute I want to like film
something so now I have a role where I'm
like I have to be cute if I'm gonna film
one thing so if I get my full glam then
I can do it but if most of time I'm not
then I can't so that I'm celery juice
trashy note I mean so I'm half and half
I need to like start obviously like
getting it together health-wise so so
once a week I transferred I have a with
my therapist in 80/20 rule worries like
80% healthy and 20% so my 24 cents on
camera and yeah and then I don't know I
don't know I have no idea where it's
gonna go another relationship I'm
looking for marriage and kids so oh yeah
how is that going because I saw that you
are officially putting yourself back on
there out on the market how is that
going so far it's rough cuz I've been on
match and they're like wait I don't have
a boyfriend and stuff but I'm I'm
looking I go around I get out more now I
want to go see Dennis Quaid Saturday
night I like front row he didn't notice
me but you know we're trying and Keanu
Reeves I put a video out for him I heard
he's lonely so I need you know I am hi
who's a dream man I like an older guy
yawns uh just someone loyal okay like
yeah I do like famous people I need to
stop but that's why I've been on match
let's try to find like regular people
today but they're also like not that
exciting but celebrities cheat on you so
I don't freaking I'm gonna be single
forever
that's why Jason was perfect he was like
a celebrity ish and then also like
regular guy but I think this will be
maybe that should be the direction your
content goes it goes in is finding
yourself a man like I would watch that
religiously just so you know everything
like The Bachelor because I'm even too
old for the bachelor at this point the
cutoff at 28 I'm like I needed my own
version I don't know like they need to
bring back like rock of love but for
like old people ah yeah let yeah we need
to do something with that girl I would
die that would be the ultimate I feel
like you would totally find love I'm
such a believer in reality she loved
it's working for some there was one
where like it was called like a proposal
and like they got proposed in the same
day that's what I need I need to know
how authentic and real are these
performance videos or is it kind of just
is it true isn't trolling us or is this
like fantasy it's authentic because like
yeah I can carry a tune but like I can't
bow but like that's my dream is to belt
like so I like what I sing shallow I was
like that's how I sing it in the car and
I feel like I thought it was like not
that terrible I'm good apparently
everyone thought it was awful and so I
was like okay cool whatever
so I just I love singing and so like if
people like it yeah Papa form a lady
Gaga especially like that's my that's my
jam I'll perform at your wedding someone
else has me fat Jewish asked me to
officiate his wedding I said yeah of
course perform at their weddings I'm
poor
oh my god yes that's gonna be bigger
than the Royal Wedding with you perform
oh my god
[Applause]
you
[Music]